the European Union is set to reap the
harvest of two days of complex
negotiations on reforming the e use
common agricultural policy or cap at
talks in brussels an overwhelming
majority of europe's agriculture
ministers have agreed on the four main
rules that will govern the way the farm
policy system works in future the cap is
designed to guarantee good living
standards for farmers and stable food
supplies at fair prices for consumers it
also helps to foster rural development
and protect the environment this is a
really significant step forward now for
the process of agreeing a final cap
reform so that we can give certainty to
our farmers to our agri-food industry to
NGOs unto rural communities across the
European Union of what the kind of
support system that Europe can offer is
going to look like for the next seven
years under the guidance of the Irish
presidency almost all EU member states
agreed a common approach on rules
governing direct payments to farmers the
organisation of markets in agricultural
products rural development support and
the way the cap is financed managed and
monitors farm policy has been
notoriously difficult to reform but
Island is optimistic that the results of
this council will enable it to forge a
common negotiating position on behalf of
the EU nations it will defend that
position in talks next month with the
European Commission and European
Parliament's pending on agriculture
accounts for a big slice of the annual
EU budget just less than forty percent
this year it's been decreasing in share
and pressures high to cut it further
amid a global economic downturn and as
member nations look to streamline the e
use main budget for the next seven years
but if all goes according to plan
ireland hopes to clinch a comprehensive
political Accord on the reforms with
Parliament by June 30